foreign
folks welcome back to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream 163 q a segment with
me Dr Brett Weinstein you Dr Heather
Hein there are questions we are going to
attempt to formulate answers working
without Annette who again did not show
up for work today we gotta fire that one
yep
okay we always begin
we always begin our q a we have sent our
producer into park systems of laughter
really does paroxysm ever get used out
of the context of of laughter can you
have paroxysms of
nausea
[Music]
and you have paroxysms of carpet
cleaning do you have practicums of
sewage
that does not sound like something that
you want to have well sure I didn't I
it's not putting it down
can it happen yeah I I don't know I will
uh admit I have to look up parax systems
because laughter is the only context I
would feel confident using the term
well as I was saying
um Annette now gone yeah but the Discord
sir okay um
employment has been canceled yes
I'm sure she'll come up again though
well that's true yeah
except that she'll have a much better
excuse for not showing up for work now
that she's been fired
it's really it's solid it's really the
ultimate excuse yeah yeah not being paid
having been fired yep yeah
okay so every week uh the wonderful
people at Discord uh propose a question
about a few questions among themselves
and they vote on which question they
would most like to see answered this
week this week we have
the following question
older High status men dating
significantly younger women make sense
from an evolutionary point of view but
we've seen the rise of so-called cougars
and female celebrities dating young toy
Boys in our lifetime
can you see any reasons for such a
pairing Beyond Simple emulation of male
High status Behavior
um yeah I mean look I think all of this
stuff is
Downstream of unusual economic facts
right so in other words it makes sense
you know the the premise of the question
it makes sense for uh older High status
men to date uh young women it makes
sense from an evolutionary perspective
only in light of the fact that actually
young women have a reason to do it which
is that not only is there
um male status that compensates those
young women for dating men who frankly
aren't going to live as long
but there is also such a huge difference
in the power of uh different potential
mates to carve out a niche for one's
brood which is what this is all about so
the point is the deeply lopsided
economics of modernity has set the stage
in which uh men acting on a very easily
understood uh predisposition find women
willing to engage them because the
difference between those you know
between a high status male and a lower
status male is huge economically
um so anyway that that's just in terms
of cleaning up the premise of the
question
as far as whether or not the cougar
phenomenon is evolutionarily sensible
[Music]
um
yes but realize when we say
evolutionarily sensible
we're talking about a phenomenon that is
built to increase the likelihood of
lodging one's genome
into the future that's what evolution is
doing
and
we as we have often said you can't judge
modern phenomena as evolutionarily
successful or not you can only look into
the past and say this thing worked that
thing didn't but modernity is noisy so
does it or can we Trace down all of the
instincts that might result in that
phenomenon both on the female side why
might they be doing this and on the male
side why might they be willing
um of course but the point is most of
this behavior isn't reproductive in the
first place so the idea that it is
evolutionarily explainable in the same
sense that uh
religion music humor Wings eyes leaves
are evolutionary it it doesn't it
doesn't have to be right so uh the the
older excuse me the older male younger
female
pairing obviously as you say has a a
sexual evolutionary
basis for existing and and does exist
across many cultures especially the more
polygenous they are the more the the
wider the Gap there tends to be in ages
between
um between parents of children
um and and that Gap is basically always
in the direction of men being older and
women being younger but uh even though
that is true it is also true as we we
lay out in our book that so much of what
humans are is sort of co-opting
something that clearly evolved for a
reason and turning it into something
that is more that is either distinctly
uniquely human or at least humans do it
even more than anyone else so just as
for humans food is not just about eating
it's not just about getting your
now the nutrients that you need to
sustain your body sex is also not just
about producing babies it's it's just
not and pretending otherwise is silly
right so you know food the sharing of
food the making of food together the
breaking of bread is in every culture I
believe uh part of how humans bond with
one another and similarly uh sexual
interaction between individuals is part
of how humans bond with one another and
the vast majority of sexual interactions
do not produce babies and that's not a
failure that's not that's not humans
being bad or weird or failing at sex any
of that it's it's us enhancing uh what
evolution handed us to to make to make
more of something that a drive that
already exists in fact it's an
adaptation right it is it is absolutely
an adaptation and so
um even though there's a clear like a
reproductive
explanation without justifying it
without saying it's it's lovely but you
know for an older man younger woman
pairing where there are children that
result there's also
um non-reproductive
um reasons that that has has been
persistent and those are you know
generally tied together right like okay
so
um you know the guy gets some nubile
Young Thing who's at her Peak fertility
and she gets a lot of resources uh well
you know the question it says in our
lifetime I don't know how old the person
is who's who's writing it but the rise
of so-called cougars and female
celebrities dating young toy boys
um In Our Lifetime may be exactly
coincident uh with the rise of
effectively
um women making more money in the
marketplace and therefore having
something to offer
um to someone who is younger and hasn't
yet had time to put away resources just
as historically it was only the purview
of older men rather than older women who
had that access to those resources
I agree exactly
all right
what have I done with the rest of the
questions there they are
awesome okay first question from
darkhorsesubmissions.com for this week
Genesis tells us about humans that lived
for hundreds of years but reach
fertility above the age of 120.
for the suspension of disbelief how
would such trade-off between longevity
and fertility fit your telomere theory
wow I was not expecting telomeres to
show up in that question no and I I mean
I guess this is obviously directed to
you more than us but I would start by
saying
um that the use of time in Genesis is
clearly metaphorical
uh that you know a day means something
different from what we understand a day
on planet earth to mean and um and yes
when you're talking about human
lifespans it would seem to be literal
but I mean that's part of you know how
how is it that we can take meaning from
these ancient texts
um that may you know we're clearly wrong
about some things
um and had assumptions
um that are not as it turns out based in
you know the actual Physical World
um but also we're trying to make meaning
that would last I don't know I don't
know to what degree you know the various
authors of the old or new testament knew
that they were trying to put something
into place that would have meaning far
far into the future but
um the the fact is that the stories that
have lasted the longest that had have
had of the most duration Through Time
played with metaphor and meaning and
story sufficiently well that you can
kind of squint at it and go like yeah
okay people never lived hundreds of
years but
um you know what if they did let's let's
see what would happen if they had even
though
um I I don't think anyone is actually
confused about thinking that that's what
humans used to do yeah so
um I often say you can't write a myth
you can write a narrative and it evolves
into a myth and so I think whatever the
so-called authors were thinking they
weren't really The Architects of these
stories what happens is somebody writes
a story or several people write a story
and then it evolves in the process of
being passed down in a very normal
evolutionary way and becomes a story
that does stuff and that story then has
weird features why does a story in which
somebody lives an improbable amount of
time or it gets swallowed by a whale or
whatever why do these things actually
resonate for so long
um but
if we take the question at face value
right we can actually
just
sort of answer it I can correct the
telomere hypothesis for such a lifespan
easily I imagine this is going to be
totally unsatisfying is this just really
a trivial
a trivial phenomenon but it's easy to do
um
the telomere hypothesis when you zoom in
on it says that at Birth
most of your tissues have a telomere
length or a mechanism that maintains
telomeres at a level that they erode at
some predictable rate
and that that predictable rate begins to
exhaust cell lines across the body at
the age of usual first reproduction of
the species
it's not an absolute clock it's not an
absolute clock but the the thing is
senescence the process by which we
become feeble and less efficient with
age does not happen as aging begins we
begin to age at the moment that we are
conceived right even as we are
developing
we do not begin to degrade until the
usual first stage of reproduction in the
species if the usual first stage of
reproduction in the species was 120
then what you would have is either
incredibly long telomeres which would
cause problems because they would result
in cancer or you would have some
mechanism that would
um
cause replacement in some sort of a
protected way such that you would uh and
you know there are tissues like this
B cells immunological cells that have to
do a lot of proliferating in the case of
disease have um active telomerase
spermatogenic tissue has active
telomerase there are a number of
epithelial tissue which gets sloughed
off into the world
um all of these things have
mechanisms that deviate from what would
be true in for example your liver right
and yours also my liver right a pretty
much everybody's liver
um even a net
her again yeah her again but uh point
being you can just sort of refactor the
basics of the system for any
distribution of Youth and then
reproductive lifespan the question of
whether you get a coherent creature out
of it is not straightforward right lots
of things change you know there are uh
there's a very interesting puzzle called
Paradox which says why don't
creatures given that cells are all
pretty similar in size because they're
limited by the surface to volume ratio
why do creatures to have more cells not
get uh overrun by uh cancers
um but anyway
you have to have all the parameters fit
together so you get a coherent creature
but from the ques from the perspective
of what would be true of a creature that
had that life history description
um yeah the two pieces fit together in
almost the same relationship as our
actual truth does in terms of lifespan
compared to
um age of first
um reproduction right uh and so the fact
that it's scaled up to an improv you
know
improbable for life on Earth under our
under our conditions to have happened
doesn't change the fact that the ratio
is still right the ratio as it were of
like how far into life does age of first
reproduction happen
right and the key thing is not that you
don't lose Fells it's that you don't
exhaust cellular lineages you begin
exhausting cellular lineages at the cusp
of reproduction
right and so aging is a very or
senescence is a very subtle phenomenon
in somebody who has just reached
reproductive age barely detectable you
can see it in certain Sports you can see
that people you know in certain Sports
age out of them relatively quickly right
that's the result of senescence and that
does not kick in you are you are not
exhausting cell lines in any appreciable
quantity until you hit that age
I would point out though
on the last little caveat okay which is
that if you were to build a creature
like that you would get certain kinds of
degradation
um that's a long time to accumulate
damage while you are not exhausting cell
lines and so a person that lived 120
years uh in this you might expect a
higher
um both miscarriage and mutation rates
you in fact you would expect some uh
some failures just as a result of the
fact that especially people who had
repeated damage in the same tissue over
that period of time so you would expect
more anomalies the long period of time
for anomalous patterns of disrupted
development to occur
[Music]
cure hesitancy exclamation point and
then there's a link
uh
two and I'm actually going to try to
click on this although it's really hard
to do with this framework uh
sorry guys I'm gonna try this
um
study
receives 3.3 million dollar Grant to
address copin 19 vaccine hesitancy among
people with anxiety or depression
foreign
since all I've seen is the headline I
don't know anything more about this
um
why are you looking at like that I did
the whole thing like okay they're going
to try to cure hesitancy that turned out
to be well founded and they're going to
Target a particular population of people
who have mood disorders to have their
head that I'm secured yeah the whole
thing is I thought this was going to be
I'll come back here but I thought
thought
this is going to be a reference to and
I'm going to find it
a story that I saw this week
and in fact I
believe I tweeted about so I'm just
going to look through here uh here it is
you can actually show my screen if you
want Zach uh
there's a article based on a plus one I
think it was research study that came
out this week that said adults who
received Copa 19 vaccines reported
short-term reduction in anxiety and
depression
that's because they were told they were
going to work right so what I said about
this was and I'll just click through
here and we'll show it but what I said
was step one ramp up anxiety to a fever
pitch scare everyone isolate them step
two promise that the solution to all
problems comes in a needle
step three quote adults who receive
covid-19 vaccines reported short-term
reductions in depression and anxiety
of course they did how could they how
could they not if they bought in if they
if they responded to your fear mongering
campaign and then they bought your fear
migraine campaign's solution to how not
to be scared anymore and then went out
and got the solution of course they were
briefly alleviated of their symptoms
until they realized that you've been
lying to them the entire time right at
which point presumably their anxiety
depression anxiety can be referring back
in spades like worse than ever before so
um yeah here's the actual
um actually just keep it on here for a
moment I've also received covid-19
vaccines I've heard short-term
reductions and depressive and anxiety
symptoms and this is a plus one article
um
published uh February 15 2023 so just
published short-term Improvement of
mental health after a covid-19
vaccination so the title of the plasma
article includes a short term because it
would have to be wouldn't it
it everyone now knows like even if you
can't see the not quite so safe are they
part of it like how effective are they
isn't everyone getting covered like
regardless of vaccination status yes yes
yeah no it's
it's a slam dunk that you were going to
find that effect here oh my goodness
yeah so anyway that's what I thought we
were being asked about it's not this um
what they should have done okay the
vaccination caused a brief reduction in
anxiety and depression and then as
reality set in a radical increase in
annoyance and frustration anger and
anger feelings of betrayal vaccine
hesitancy booster hesitate
version didn't work
um
yeah so I don't know this this
piece we're being asked about now which
actually shows up on the same sort of
Clearinghouse of medical news as uh the
one I was just talking about quote in
March 2021 about 40 of us adults with
symptoms of anxiety or depression were
vaccinated compared to 53 of those
without symptoms
says Cooney School of Public Health
distinguished Professor Dennis Nash
um under vaccination is a key driver of
the preventable outcomes of
hospitalizations deaths and long covet
and this is what has motivated our
research team to conduct this study
so
I would say
anxiety and depression turn out to have
a somewhat surprising protective effect
against Adverse Events well you I you
might say that hearing this but I'm
remembering one of the papers that we
covered earlier uh
one of the really good papers that
actually went through like and tried to
figure out what all the comorbidities
were and for covid and uh and how
relatively important they were and
anxiety and depression were on this list
yeah so um this would seem to run
counter I'm not exactly sure how to
parse that in the age of vaccination no
no that if I understood it correctly
um anxiety and depression were
comorbidities for covid and this makes
them protective against uh basically
being Bamboozled by faucism into taking
a dangerous pharmaceutical yeah okay
so those are consistent they're I mean
it's I find that it's all surprising but
well it's it's bad news
um you know if
I mean it just raises all sorts of
questions about what anxiety and
depression are like what what what's the
ideology and how many different things
yeah what is it let's put aside
depression anxiety like you know
presumably like everyone now knows to
say with regard to depression clinical
depression is different from being sad
is different from like most of us have
never experienced clinical depression
but all of us have felt like oh I'm
depressed today right it's different
maybe that same language exists for
anxiety
I don't actually know but imagine for a
moment that it does like clinical
anxiety is something that most of us
have never experienced being anxious
about an upcoming this that or the other
is not the same thing
I would still say though that
um
I don't believe that I trust their
assessment
that anxiety
is going to be very often just as
depression a um an appropriate response
to a life circumstance or a set of
Developmental circumstances that you
cannot change or have not come up with a
solution for how to change if it's in
the present and you cannot escape and
your brain is basically trying to inform
you over and over and over again or
consistently keep
keep working on this like you got to
figure out a way out and at some point
it feels like I'm not working on this
this is just hopeless this is futile I'm
nothing good is happening here and I
think that is what people who are
anxious and depressed will say it's like
I'm not doing any good for myself this
is not helping but but you know the
original
signal from the brain of actually
everything's not hunky-dory like there
is there is something that needs to be
fixed that is not something that should
be Vindicated away of course I mean
right it's like it's and to the point uh
in the initial podcast the
non-evolutionary nature of medicine and
right psychology totally tends to take
things like pain and anxiety and
discomfort and all of these things and
assume that they are pathological
because they are unpleasant yeah and the
point is no every one of those things is
an adaptation and to the extent that
there is a medical question it is about
a pathological manifestation of anxiety
having anxiety when there's nothing to
be anxious about yeah but if you don't
separate those two things like oh the
person's in pain treat it yeah is the
person in pain because they're being
crushed by a car right and so like okay
so if if I'm remembering correctly and
and anxiety and depression are important
comorbidities for covid
does that mean maybe is it possible that
those people were anxious and depressed
because they actually had some
underlying health issue that hadn't been
diagnosed by the system yet which
actually made them more likely to come
down with a bad case of covet
I feel like that's at least a working
hypothesis that I would like to see
addressed could be right or I mean you
know this is not intended to be ironic
or a joke though it could be taken that
way it is also possible that people with
anxiety and depression sufficient to be
diagnosed as such have had more than
their share of interaction with medical
science they've probably been betrayed
more than once you know having having
been prescribed something that had a
short-term benefit at a long-term harm
or whatever and so the idea that oh now
we're in a medical emergency and guess
who's in charge the same nut jobs who
have you know bungled the response to
anxiety and depression and declared this
the result of chemical imbalances or any
other overtimes
um
that I you seem to be explaining why
they might be anxious about about the
pandemic but not why they'd be more
likely to get covered so I you know yep
you're right uh I'm responding to the
second of the two uh apparently paired
phenomena the um the uh the vaccine
hesitancy yes yeah yeah so anyway being
in the system might mean uh that you are
more likely to be hesitant about the
system Solutions and it also I thought
this is where you were going it also
might mean as to you know related to the
crap paper that I talked about last week
um if you're in the system because
you're being treated for anxiety or
depression you might be more likely to
end up with a positive test for covid
not because you are more likely to have
gotten covet but because you are more
likely to be tested at some point ah
exactly like the paper you talked about
last week exactly yeah
all right
not the right tab there we go okay
next question
maxilla and mandible orthognathic
surgery to correct malocclusion and
underbite at 35.
can you do a cost benefit for future
physiological benefits
boy so I don't know what all is involved
in maxilla and mandible orthognathic
surgery and I'm just trying to put it
like I
I've never run into the surgery before
uh yeah maxilla and mandible are um this
is pre-max so it's basically the these
these points
um uh the mandible's lower jaw the max
is the is a big part of the upper job
and not all of it
um
orthognathic and that's just means jaw
you know I I don't know what they're
doing
I don't know what they're doing I mean
it says two correct malocclusion an
underbite but like why both then why are
they moving both both Jaws
so this is not how I would approach the
puzzle yeah I would say
um I've been through a version of this
although I didn't have jaw surgery I did
go through did you go after your bones
right they never touched your actual
Cranium Cranium skeleton well I mean you
know the implants involve uh drilling
into yeah drilling into yeah bone graft
uh all of that stuff and I can tell you
having puzzled over that that the basic
point is there is no way to map all of
the potential consequences you are
gambling on unknowns here even in the
case of something that is regularly done
like implants yeah the point is this is
a new enough technology that the
question of what it's what the
implication of you know uh any of these
things the boring into the bone you know
all kinds of you know there's brain
pathologies that seem to be related to
you know mouth ecology uh so anyway
there's all it's a complex system and
he
the other problem that I would say is
whatever the surgery in question is I
can guarantee you
that the state of your jaw is one off
you know sure there's an Anna Karenina
principle here right all happy families
are like all unhappy families are
unhappy in their own individual way
all functional airplanes are alike all
airplane crashes are unique events every
malformed jaw is going to be its own
phenomenon and so the question is how
many unknowns in terms of future
pathologies are the result of the fact
that even if your surgeon has seen a
thousand cases like yours yeah
um each one has its own idiosyncratic
nature and that they have to address
them so really the question is how bad
is your pathology oh exactly
malocclusion and underbite you know
malocclusion
if you've learned how to deal with it
and you haven't broken any teeth yet you
know maybe you could keep doing so on
the other hand everything gets more
brittle and harder to maintain with
precision as you age and having a bite
that is not mal you know having having
your occlusion your two sets of chompers
fit together the way
um that you know they they evolved to is
going to allow for a much
easier
middle and old age that you're coming up
on
um approaching middle age at 35 right
um and underbite you know correcting an
underbite I guess I don't
I don't know what
I feel like that is just part of the
malocclusion question I don't know what
its implications are health-wise other
than the malocclusion well unfortunately
uh as we've learned from Mike mu there
are a huge number of implications of
malformed Jaws and the problem is if you
say oh malocclusion well you've just
named one problem in a spectrum of
problems the one problem is the teeth
not meeting correctly right you can
correct that by moving teeth you can
correct that by reforming Jaws right but
the point is there were a lot of other
consequences of the Jaws not you know do
you have breathing issues sleep apnea
might this might this resolve sleep
apnea or might it resolve sleep apnea
does it have a chance of resolving sleep
apnea but you're definitely going to go
through an Adaptive Valley first to
learn again how to breathe in your sleep
and you're going to have six months of
really bad sleeping but if at the end of
it you're going to sleep better than you
ever have before that's probably worth
it
um but you know is your your masseter
your big chewing muscle here and all the
other muscles are probably going to need
are going to need to learn how to do
some new things and that's going to be
challenging uh I know what I'd do
I would go look up Mike Mew and see if
you can't get a consult and just see
whether somebody who can do this
behaviorally well maybe but I would just
run the plan by Dr Mew and I would say
look you know he'll do it and if there's
of your jaw and then just say is this
the approach that you know is the
biggest bang for the buck in terms of
risk is this the approach that I should
be taking and yeah uh well but if he's
not available I suspect you know just as
this book why we get sick is still I
can't I never get it on camera
um
is uh
is the book that exists for darwinian
medicine there you know there are
darwinian doctors out there they're just
not very many of them there are
darwinian dentists out there there is
evolutionary Dentistry right so if you
even if you can't find Mike mu you know
look in your area for anyone who calls
themself an evolutionary dentist a
darwinian dentist yeah
I wish I knew the landscape of who's out
there and how much they know yeah
um I don't the first place I would start
is somebody with a known track record
who is also known to be sensitive to all
of the various systems that are
interacting there's one person in the
world so that's that's you can direct
you to somebody else they can get his
attention
so did you have more to say no okay
does does chemistry have simple
heuristics where you can make reliable
predictions for reactions biology seems
more intuitive with its principles
um
yes they're I mean you know the the
periodic table is a miraculous
heuristic
that groups things according to their
electron configurations and their
electron configurations are
almost the subtotal of chemistry until
you get to nuclear yeah it's much it's
less at at least at the
sort of college level inorganic organic
pchem
istry level physical chemistry level
it seems less noisy right like it's it's
not chaotic like it's really highly
predictable it's highly predictable
right yeah it's not intuitive
necessarily like I I don't find
chemistry particularly intuitive
um and so I maybe there's maybe there's
two different questions here so
does chemistry have simple heuristics
where you can make reliable predictions
for reactions biology seems more
intuitive with its principles
I think you know presumably I would hope
that professional professional chemists
find chemistry more intuitive it's part
of why they went into it
um that it you know it just it works for
their brain for their way of thinking
about things uh but reliable predictions
and intuitive are not the same thing
yep now I would say
there's a an important distinction worth
having in your mind
we group things like biology and
chemistry and physics together because
the scientific process that we use to
figure out how they work is closely
related
they are not naturally grouped together
as phenomena
physics and chemistry are naturally
grouped and biology psychology
and Engineering would be better grouped
together because engineering yep
here's why and I can say biology and
geology
are are grouped in a way that nothing
else there's a way to group them but why
does engineering Belong With Biology and
psychology because there is an objective
phenomena in which there is something to
be accomplished or fundamentally
different than phenomena in which there
is no success or failure right a photon
either does or does not strike a surface
right it's not good that it strikes the
surface it just does or does not right
the rabbit escaping from the fox that is
success for the rabbit and failure for
the fox and so systems in which there's
something to be accomplished
are different and the reason what you
are calling intuitive
that where where Heather and I are
saying chemistry is not intuitive to us
right in part it's because it's a
totally different landscape of stuff
right at the end of the day you can walk
into a forest and you can look at any
creature and you could know before you
learn anything about it what it's trying
to do at a very basic level and then you
can try to unpack what you see it doing
in light of that objective that you can
assume right you can't play that game in
chemistry or physics or geology so
anyway I'm not arguing that you can't
group these things different ways but
I'm arguing I think I think engineering
showing up over in involved space will
not work for some for some categories
yep much as and you know really all of
biology and geology can't go together
but evolution evolution of biology and
geology go together as the historical
Sciences
where what you are doing is describing
something that happened once and only
once because that's the way of history
and you're trying to infer it um
from the past and thus make predictions
about the future and historical science
is actually more like history the study
of human history than it is like
psychology or chemistry at an
evidentiary level geology and biology
belong together at a objective level
that is is there an objective then
engineering belongs with Biology and you
can just test this yeah if an alien
spacecraft crashed
here on Earth here on Earth or somewhere
else and we never knew about it
in let's say in Saskatchewan
picking on the saskatchew
saskatchewanese again are we all right
in Cambodia
let's go back to Saskatchewan it's
closer it's easier to get there it'll be
cheaper the thought experiment is
cheaper for us so it crashes not the way
the cost of thought experiments works
I kind of like it I think they should
have a budget just to sort of keep you
on your game but anyway okay
alien spacecraft crashes in Saskatchewan
so I've heard okay we now want to look
at that aircraft or that craft and
figure out how it works okay if you went
into it doesn't anymore it crashed
well it depends how well it was built
but
you go into the thing you got a lot of
whirly gigs and
right do you
I don't know alien spacecraft but here's
the point
let's say that there's a
uh a box oh right
yeah a box that's box no okay
on the alien spacecraft right we would
have some confidence in assuming that
that box served the interests of those
who wish to get that craft across space
either it's navigational or it's
involved in propulsion otherwise check
off wouldn't have put it there in the
first place
well the checkoff principle that's great
it's exactly exact but but here's the
thing right you cannot walk into a
geological structure and make any
assumptions about the goodness Badness
that they don't know knock yourself out
you're making no assumptions at all
having walked into a big piece of
rockets the lag might yes all right this
has gotten silly but my point is the
assumption that you can make about a
creature if you see a creature any
creature right and it squawks right you
do not imagine oh that creature is
wasting its energy some people do a lot
of people do those are not the good
biologists the good biologists knows
that although I don't know why it's
squawked that it has a reason to squawk
right doesn't mean that every instance
of squawking is productive but the but
if it squawks then squaxing
is that even how you say that no that's
walking but I'll bet there are squawking
Birds on squax on island there probably
are it's a long squax from here but yeah
a little high 11 South Puget Sound but
nonetheless the point is the ability to
just simply say I don't have to worry
that the structure on that creature or
that expensive behavior that the
creature is involved in is productive
relative to the creature's objective I
don't have to worry that you know they
loaded a lot of random useless onto
a spacecraft that then flew you know
between Stars my point is ah I bet you
that's spacecraft uh brought only the
right stuff right I can make that
assumption and now although they did
crash
well that's probably because they were
drunk
um they brought too much of the right
stuff or they picked some up here they
got here noticed people drinking and oh
you think that's how across cross uh
cross Evolution physiology is going to
work no idea but um in any case the
ability to assume an objective is what
makes stuff
intuitive it's where if we look at a
creature doing stuff we've never seen
before right the point is I wonder why
it's doing that we don't well how do you
know it's doing it for some reason
because it's a goddamn creature it's
what they do right yep no and this is
part of why there's a there's a very
naive very persistent things like well
don't anthropomorphize like well
actually a lot of what is being called
anthropomorphization
anthropomorphization of animal behavior
is actually this is what animals do and
we've imagined this is just a human
special thing it's like no actually
humans figured this out a long time
after everyone else did and yes we want
to use the scientific method to reduce
our bias as much as possible and not
attribute meaning and human-like emotion
and all of this when it doesn't belong
there but in general you know do do
other organisms you know have have
drives that are similar to many human
drives of course they do of course they
do and but Rocks Don't and electrons
don't right and stalactites don't which
is a kind of Rock so I'm repeating
myself but also you have to know the
limits of actually that's not a rock
it's just that's rock yeah
totally
um it's like mites aren't I got confused
no stalagmites are mites which are they
might be corrected or might not ah there
might not and therefore are stalagmites
or something
um
I think you're gonna love this next
question really well I know I wanted to
just put the one but I think by the way
I never for a second believe that
stagmites weren't rocks I just thought
it might lead somewhere nice but we've
got to know the limits of this hey I bet
there's always a slug right angle
yes it's usually vertical yes
um yeah that was a very inside joke that
we will explain at some point in the
future maybe yeah yeah
um
by the way George Hammond if you were
out there you and your might angle they
live on in our mythology in this family
um the the limit of the ability to say
ah the creature is doing that for some
reason
would be let's take an example
back when I was a kid
my family no this one's good back when I
was a kid my family used to watch Nature
Documentaries yes some of which were
very informative and some of which were
very misinformative there was one
particularly terrifying nature
documentary that I recall on something
called African turning disease which is
a disease of uh wildebeest
in which a parasite crawls into the ear
of a wildebeest and lays an egg I think
on the brain of the animal causing it to
go insane and turn in circles until it
starves to death
it's a very awful pathology yeah yeah
bad right now is it real yes apparently
now I went to Africa as a child
expecting to see wildebeest turning and
starving to death everywhere I saw not a
one I must have seen hundreds of
thousands of these greeters because
they're in large numbers in certain
places and didn't see it once but anyway
apparently there's enough out there to
make a documentary or at least there
were but you introduced this by saying
that you watched a lot that were full of
information a lot of that were full of
bad information are you certain that
this is an actual I'm pretty sure it's a
real thing what I think it is you know
you and I have
many times taken people into for example
a tropical forest and had them expect to
see predation events happening around
them which of course they are yes but
it's hard to see right
um for reasons right because if
creatures weren't that easily observed
they'd get consumed by things that would
observe them and then eat them so
they're very good at hiding well
in this case I believe African turning
disease is real but this documentary
wildly uh overestimated the degree to
which you were likely or implied well
otherwise it doesn't make for a very
good documentary and this is the thing I
used to say to my students who would be
disappointed at first or maybe in some
cases continuously when I take them to
the Amazon
it's like okay
why don't you go figure out a human to
watch to do a focal and extended focal
watch on for a week and then come back
and tell me how much the time they spent
getting in fights and having sex which
is what you want to see if you're
looking at monkeys or parrots or
something and how much of the time they
just spent like doing this and sleeping
right and maybe shoveling food in their
mouth yeah going to Subway
um so yeah you know the monkeys in the
Amazon are a hell of a lot more
interesting to watch than most humans
exactly yeah but anyway okay African
turning disease you cannot go onto the
African Savannah and should you be lucky
enough or unlucky enough to see a
wildebeest turning to death uh on the
Savannah you cannot say ah it's turning
for a purpose it must be trying to get
its genes into the future by turning
right it doesn't work so you have to
basically the point is
can I assume that every appendage on an
animal is an adaptation to a point you
can't you know it doesn't work for a
tumor right right can I assume every
behavior is productive well not a
one-off behavior but a behavior that is
repeated across you know a particular
call that a creature has yes that's a
that's an adaptation unless it is the
result of a pathology right so the the
conditions the test for adaptation that
you generated that I think we put in the
book and that you used to teach with
includes you know is it is it persistent
over time
um is it I don't actually know if this
one shows up in the test but it has to
be you know across the the species right
it's if you know a tumor a one-off thing
you know a person with a tail
um that tail is not inherently an
adaptation because most people don't
have it
um so it's it's uh persistent over time
it's variable and extent it's complex
complex which of course you can squidge
around with exactly what is meant by
complex and as a cost and has a cost
which
um probably and I think we've talked
about this before but you know if it's
if it's variable an extent and complex
it's going to have a cost but
um say it just to make it explicit yeah
yeah um and anyway and it doesn't have
to be every individual right
yes but it but it it can't just be one
right an individual then it doesn't
persist across evolutionary time there's
no way to demonstrate that there's
actually a you know a humpback is not
right well humpback whale is full of
adaptations but they humped back to
person is yeah that is not an adaptation
because you don't see it it's not a
pattern that moves across time
um anyway so I think we've I think we've
done it but the ability to assume that
an appendage or a behavior is productive
relative to the objective that all
creatures share allows us to make
biology intuitive in a way that
chemistry and physics are not inherently
indeed
okay ready
yep do you have thoughts on religious
and psychedelic experience of unity of
self and other feature bug or neither
was it more common in our ancestral past
or only privy to shamans and Mystics
uh wow
so many so many things
um
I don't know what you mean by
the unity aspect
of unity of self and other yeah I don't
it may be supposed to say or
yeah I don't know what the parenthetical
is there what I would say is
many cultures most cultures throughout
human history and prehistory have had
some
psychedelic
mode of access whether it's
sweat lodges or mushrooms or other
extreme phenomena that
licking only the very very right frogs
the very right frogs not the wrong ones
right
um
so there's no question that humans have
used modes that access the Psychedelic
experience
adaptively it is adaptive it passes the
Adaptive test as we were just talking
about
um
In some cultures it's every member of
society
um you know the we troll for example
in some cultures
northern Mexico
everyone in the culture was expected at
some point to do a long pilgrimage
in the search for peyote in the search
for peyote and to engage with the Peyote
directly yep I believe there are a
number of cultures where this is true
there are some cultures in which even
kids are uh welcomed in on the
Psychedelic experience and there are
other cultures where this is limited to
shamans who right you know this maybe
this is a safety mechanism or a shaman
can access uh parts of Consciousness
that are shielded from normal
functioning people
um but the shaman because it is one
individual can you know their Insight
can be welcomed and it can be uh
attenuated based on whether or not it
seems sensible but in any case yes
psychedelia is used adaptively by
culture after culture after culture what
its meaning is in the modern
circumstance this is a power tool very
easily abused but it is worth
considering because we do seem to be in
a phase
in which civilization is making less and
less sense and uh because our ancestors
have used this tool in order to
um
presumably in some ways increase the
creativity of parts of the mind that are
hard to access to utilize it this might
be a moment at which at least some
people should utilize that mechanism
yeah absolutely I don't know
I have not read I am not aware of an
explanation of how
the very many cultures in which uh
psychedelic experience uh was either a
regular part of the experience for
everyone or in which there were people
like shamans or Mystics who were always
being encouraged to um to
to share the wisdom that they had
generated from from these experiences
you know
how that became today like what you know
what among the European traditions for
instance which um you know many of us
are descended from to what degree was
their psychedelic experience among the
various
um the various European groups I don't
know I don't I don't know the answer to
that
uh you you have something yeah there is
one oh I guess let me say
um except that
Barbara ehrenreich's excellent book
dancing in the streets which is a
basically a history of extasis a history
of of the ecstatic uh and Collective Joy
I think that's the subtitles I guess you
have Collective Joy she talks a lot
about the ancient Greeks so the ancient
Greeks had a history and I don't know to
what degree although I suspected they
had some number of things that they were
using to um to explore psychedelia
um
beyond the ancient Greek so like there's
a there's a big gap in my understanding
of you know between like that and
Timothy Leary like I just I don't know I
don't know what
european-ish people were doing
psychedelic wise between then well there
so the story is a tangled one I've
delved a little bit I should delve
further but
fly a garlic in northern Europe yeah
right there is controversy what is it
Fly guard is it a mushroom oh yeah very
it's a very dramatic looking mushroom oh
it's like red spot or something yeah
it's a very dramatic looking mushroom
um it's kind of easy uh so my
understanding is
lion guard has been demonized
over the connection the supposed
connection to the Berserkers basically
Warriors who took it and went crazy and
decimated enemies on the battlefield
whether or not that story is even true
is controversial
um but
it turns out there are people in modern
times Reviving fly agaric as a mushroom
that they utilize and these people I've
actually been in contact with one of
these people yeah it's a very
interesting uh puzzle it's a diff it's
not a psilocyb it's a different uh it's
a different hallucinogen effectively and
apparently there are ways of utilizing
it uh responsibly without poisoning
yourself now without going on killing
sprees
presumably yeah I guess that's included
in a responsibility yeah responsibly
yeah
um but anyway I find I find it
interesting and the what little bit is
available online is certainly
provocative but in any case as an answer
to the question that was apparently
taking place in northern Europe northern
Europe
um in historical times
and uh
it is yet another example what's what
went on in Central Europe I don't know
yeah
can you speculate if and how the field
of evolutionary ecology might be
different today at Robert H MacArthur
not past so young
wow
um
well boy
I'm not trying to do that off the cuff
I I I sort of think I I know okay
um so MacArthur was a uh an
ornithologist who had a deeply
evolutionary
viewpoint on ecology and in my opinion
at least what happened to ecology
was that it made a Bad Bet That ecology
mainstream ecology
effectively bet that you could forego
the evolutionary questions and study
species interactions in real time and
discover what you needed to know which
is of course sometimes true but
frequently enough not true that actually
by dispensing with an evolutionary
Viewpoint I think ecology became a very
uninteresting science it failed on its
uh promise to explain
patterns because if you think about it
let's take an example
if you
have a 500 year drought right the worst
drought that you're likely to see in 500
years
every creature that is there after the
drought is radically altered right these
are the most drought tolerant creatures
anything that wasn't drought tolerant is
gone right the next year may not be a
drought at all
and so now you're looking at a bunch of
Highly drought tolerant creatures in an
environment that does not make sense of
that pattern they've got excess capacity
they have excess capacity exactly and so
now if you try to think about well is
that excess capacity and trade-offs
being what they are should they shed
that excess capacity well that drought
500 year drought is likely to reoccur in
500 years so you know the point is
unfortunately for the ecologists the
question never escapes being an
evolutionary one right it only looks
like it does and so
um MacArthur understood this MacArthur
was very very uh insightful you know one
of my favorite insights of his is
um that creatures tend to be limited by
competition at the southern this is in
the northern hemisphere in the southern
end of their range and limited by
abiotic factors at the northern limit of
their range right this is so profound
with respect to its implications for why
the range is what it is in the first
place that well it seems to be that's
typical of his kind of thinking where he
encapsulated
he he observed patterns and was able to
generalize about what what they meant in
a way that we see very little love in
ecology now and I was trying to pull up
my version of the paper which somehow
I'm not able to MacArthur and Wilson 67
I think it is
theory of Island by a geography right it
was just one of and this is uh EO Wilson
who
he's still alive no he's not he just
died yeah um
but um you know at some level you know
some two of the the powerhouses of
ecology and evolution from the 60s
getting together to try to figure out
you know why why we see the diversity of
organisms on islands that we do and
um they you know they came up with
um basically distance from The Source
population and size of the island being
the two parameters that were most
predictive right which is so and it
seems so it's one of these things and
this is a phrase that we have used like
we even briefly considered naming our
book this obvious in retrospect like so
much of evolutionary thinking
no one came up with it no one came up
with it no one came up with it and then
you say it you're like well yeah
obviously and it's really actually hard
to remember not knowing and so once you
hear with regard to like oh you know why
did Cuba and Jamaica have different
um abundances and distributions of
lizards on them like well okay look at
the size of the island and the distance
to the mainland The Source population
and you'll get a long way there and yeah
which is two really simple parameters
which is no one before MacArthur and
Wilson had put together two really
simple non-biotic parameters that was
the thing yeah right yeah
and also not not about latitude like it
it it it is um independent of latitude
yep
uh so what I would say is I think there
was a moment at which
ecology if it had if it
counter-intuitively held on to its
evolutionary connections could have been
among the most vibrant biological
sciences right that there's the sort of
Eric Pianka moment where you know the
fleshing out of what the landscape might
look like and then somehow it looks like
too much work to be ecologists and so
they abandoned ship
um and anyway there's a lot to be done
yeah actually pioca is is a bit um
MacArthur like in terms so
um he he wrote what I think may be the
only textbook that I ever I never
actually required it um but I the only
textbook that I ever recommended to
students evolutionary ecology tight
little book
um just just so good yep yep
um Bianca has a a whole toolkit that
should have become the basis for the
field that should be evolutionary
ecology
um Rosen swag knows quite a bit knows
quite a bit Sterns absolutely
um
so anyway the point is the stuff to
build the field that should be ecology
yeah it's out there and uh
the degree to which a colleges spend all
of their time inventing New Waves to
avoid evolution is stunning
indeed
that time why suck
um
okay uh we'll do a couple couple more uh
I've got several here we'll try to get
through a couple more here
um does the likelihood of being gay
increase with the amount of older first
cousins not just older brothers it's a
great question a right-handed male has
that's a great question
um I would predict that it does yeah but
only if
oh but only if you're right-handed no no
that's been that's the question okay
only if you only if you encounter them
only if you know them only if they're in
your life only if they are in your natal
environment and the problem is that this
is going to be swamped out
because you're uh well
probably so the question is where does
this get assessed does this get assessed
by the uh
well okay no no
there's a uterine effect yeah yeah right
yeah your mother's physiology knows how
many older brothers you have are
supposed to have
um so it can't possibly be as strong
because there's at least one effect
that's not possible between first
cousins it depends yeah if this is done
by the mother's physiology then the
cousins ought to have no impact because
it's not measured right if this is
partially assessed by a creature after
they are born then probably in modern
times one does not do a good job of
distinguishing cousins from everybody
else and so it might be assessed on the
basis of you know how many males of you
know are in close proximity
um
uh so anyway something in there probably
the point is this is swamped out by
noise of other things in modern times
um but in principle if you had an
isolated population you might be able to
measure such an effect yeah
the current outbreak of bird flu is
carried by wild birds but kills domestic
birds at a near 100 rate supposedly why
don't domestic Birds develop the same
immunity as wild birds
well boy it raises the question of what
we've been selecting for
um in domestication well
there is uh I reserve the right to
rethink this and take it back later
always but
the error that creates
unrealistic long telomere mice that make
Pharmaceuticals look much safer than
they are that error is actually an
economic error and the error is I would
like to breed as many of these Critters
as I can for as little investment of
money what are the chances of the people
who are breeding chickens want to make
as much money as they can well we
actually know that chickens have the
same telomere elongation we do we know
this yeah so presumably from the same
economic motivation you want to produce
chickens at the highest rate that means
you're breeding young chickens so
here's the question
to what extent is selection muted
because you are not looking at the
longevity of chickens
you are looking at the rate that the
dominant fact in the breeding colonies
of chickens is who breeds at a very high
rate young which is in a trade-off
relationship with who has the immunity
to last a long time in the face of
disease and that we've just selected for
the wrong damn thing again yeah we
selected for breed fast Die Young not
robust across uh lifespan yep which will
tend to be tend to be about immune
response in part yep
very good
um
I don't know what this one means but
it has the word snake in it so I'm going
to read it awesome can you comment on
the genetic experimentation that is
snake morph breeding
I think I can't because I have no idea
what this refers to but it's interesting
enough that I will look into it well we
could guess make more breeding well like
the breeding of I mean if it's eyelash
vipers it's going to be color morph
but what else what other morphs like uh
albino pythons and things
yeah
um
I'm not sure what to say well yeah let's
just say there are certain
the examples I can think of are plant
examples but there are certain
creatures
that
are only known
from a domesticated form
there's a
euphorb plant in Madagascar that is only
known from
formal Gardens and things
there is a there is
thalvia uh
just Salvia specific epithe salvia
it's diviners Sage some form of divinium
something like that
um but anyway that one is only known
from The Gardens of the people who
utilize it as their their backup
hallucinogen for
um for magic mushrooms but anyway
spare tire hallucinogen You Can't Always
Get the mushrooms they're very finicky
and so you have this other plant that
allows you to to access that state but
anyway the point is
people
having taken creatures out of the wild
then breeding them for certain morphs
could produce something
novel and interesting that would not
endure nature would not successfully
compete out in nature but could even
persist as a domesticated form of a uh
yeah she's not here but anyway the point
is those experiments can result in
marvelous things 30 000 years later yeah
um but some of those marvelous things
slink off and sleep in the corner they
they do slink off and sleep in some
Corners somewhere but anyway so I guess
the point is
um I'm a little worried that people
might breed things
that are Curiosities that are it's not
really fair to the critter
to burden them you know like oh I've got
an example well I guess if if we really
are talking about like albino Bowens uh
like you know
I'm not too worried at that level I mean
there's a lot going on in the herp trade
the the pet trade for herps um that
isn't great um and you know I I saw it
directly these leaf-tailed geckos you're
a plateus just amazing geckos that are
endemic to Madagascar that so perfectly
engage in crypsis on the surface of a
tree that you can like I like you can be
like sliding down a hill and reach to
grab a tree and not realize until your
hand is on like oh that's a lizard they
blend in so perfectly and then once
they're um once they're not trying to
blend in they've got this bright red
interior of their mouths and they've got
you know these flanges but like little
little claws on the tips of their of
their fingers and they're just
remarkable animals and they're really
popular in the pet trade and so the
island that I worked on off the coast of
Madagascar
um we'd see occasionally people coming
in and
um
and bagging them and selling them to pet
Traders and the local the local malagazi
men would get a buck a lizard and then
they're selling for hundreds of dollars
a piece uh in in the pet trade in the US
and Europe presumably and what ends you
know they just they just live this
captive life and and it's it's miserable
and it's not you know it's not good for
anyone except maybe the person who
thinks they're taking Joy from having
this lizard in a cage and I like I I
love lizards I like interacting with
them wherever I run into them but it's
it's not a good a good scene that said
once you have a population in captivity
and you are breeding them and they are
um and they're in captivity
and there is demand to um you know for
people who know how to take care of them
well to continue to have them in
captivity I don't I don't think that
there's anything inherently wrong with
that and breeding for a particular Wharf
that was already showing up doesn't
strike me you know it's
how is that different from breeding for
all these cat and dog breeds and frankly
bunny breeds that you know we've got but
um and and frankly in a snake the
implications for personality are going
to be a lot less because snake
personality is a lot less
yeah I was thinking of the um
Veil Tales
goldfish that you sometimes see which
are apparently uh just the result of
breeding to you know the way mums are
bred chrysanthemums yeah they're bred
for uh doubling of petals right there
lots of flowers are doubled yeah
um so anyway the veil-tailed uh goldfish
are apparently the same thing it's not a
wild creature it's a it's a
developmental error that can be produced
that produces a very pretty little
goldfish in
um you know
I don't know what goldfish think about
the world maybe it's just fine to be you
know maybe it's better to be a goldfish
in a bowl where somebody thinks to feed
you and change the water and
um you know you don't have to worry
about getting eaten and you know the
fact that you swim atrociously is not
bad because you know where to go
I mean right maybe that's cool I've
never been a goldfish so I don't know
for sure but it sounds like it might be
all right yep
all right uh well maybe maybe let me
just maybe that's the place
uh to finish
um
okay one more
what are the evolutionary benefits of a
person becoming ideologically possessed
person becoming ideologically well
I don't really know how to answer it but
it looked like a place I think we can do
it I think the point is
this makes the assumption that
ideological possession is an adaptation
in some circumstances right
which I think it probably is right
there's probably
look
let's talk about the question of
Wanderlust
Wanderlust Wanderlust okay
your population fills up an environment
right there's a question about whether
or not in that full environment to
become good at competition and eke out a
living where there's no free resource or
New Opportunities because everybody's
exploiting everything and everything's
been figured out right then there's a
question of am I better off doing that
or am I better off heading off across
the Horizon maybe dying because there's
nowhere to go or because I'll head in
the wrong direction and I will end up
drowning but
maybe I'll find a place that isn't full
of competitors right so the point is
it is adaptive
to think about the possibility of
heading out and attempting to innovate
something new when the opportunity that
the competing opportunity is just
not very likely to yield uh any any way
forward or any productive way for it you
could tread water at best
um
so the point is you know sometimes when
we joke about why did why would anybody
have stopped here this is such a hard
environment to live in why would anybody
have stopped here not here right but the
answer is that's not how it works people
go until they find a good opportunity
they fill that place up and then they
backfill the places that are possible to
live in but are much harder to live in
right so it's not every place that
people live wasn't inherently a first
choice right and so the point is you
keep going until it stops getting better
right and then you're like hey this is
the place and then the point is you're
the fact that you're now competing there
makes that place slightly worse and so
Place fills up from the delightful
opportunity to the marginal
opportunities okay so suppose that
instead of geographically moving what
you do is you move to a new way of
viewing the world let's say you go from
hunter-gatherer to Farmer right
and then the point is oh well actually
this farming thing you know it's really
got something to it you know you it does
take a lot of work and you got to pay
attention to the patterns but then you
know you invest you know exactly where
to go gather your foods and right so the
point is what you don't want is to well
I wonder if there's something even
better than farming well I don't know
why don't you do it for 5 000 years and
then at the point that you've exhausted
that opportunity then go look for some
new thing to do so the point is the
ideological possession might be constant
change isn't a value right change free
yeah you don't want you know at the
point you've landed in the delightful
place where you have no competitors you
don't want your Wanderlust to get you
moving somewhere new because you're
going to take a great opportunity and
you're going to throw it away for
something that is almost certainly worse
right yeah and actually a lot a lot of
moderns do have that it's sort of a
um
it too generally applied
desire to see what's Over the Horizon
yep well right you can get addicted to
that thing and in fact maybe that there
maybe the point is you are that morph
right your civilization shouldn't move
after you've found someplace great but
maybe the point is your purpose is yeah
yeah the geographical rather than the
Psychedelic Shaman right so as an
individual it might be a valid strategy
but the idea you know you don't come
back to the camp at night and say
this place is great but let's just keep
going see if there's another even
greater place the point is you guys stay
here I'll go look for some greater place
but point is
ideological Obsession or whatever the
capture I don't remember what it said I
I've clicked it already
um it's gone an obsession with a
particular Viewpoint might be the
correct reaction to an innovation that
has unlocked something amazing right
where the experiment has yet to fill in
the container and to discover all of the
possibilities that have been Unleashed
and so the point is you know
uh the West for example right the West
figured out that if you put aside your
racial differences and you collaborate
with people on the basis that they have
things that you don't and you have
things that they don't and you just sort
of see where it goes the point is
actually that's magic right it results
in all kinds of innovation and it
results in the uh safer more peaceful
more delightful more fascinating more
fun world and so the point is you know
you get ideologues who are you know
absolutely obsessed with freedom right
and maybe they even miss the point about
the fact that freedom does eventually
run into competing uh concerns but while
you're still benefiting from it you
might as well be obsessed with it
because the point is really hey we've
got this new tool it is producing
dividends for us you know non-stop so
the point is let's not deviate from that
tool until it begins to show signs that
it's run its course
awesome good place to stop all right
all right consider joining us for our
private q a tomorrow at 11 A.M
11 A.M Pacific on Sunday February 26th
yes that's that's the ticket
that's the ticket where's that from
Saturday Night Live
uh gosh it was a ticket that's the
ticket uh Pat Sajak soon pretty decent
guy I must say I don't know I can't
remember was it Martin Short or was it
before Martin Short no it might have
been Martin Short could have been Martin
Short it could have been Martin sure
anyway uh consider joining us tomorrow
at 11 A.M Pacific it's Sunday February
26th for our private q a you can get
there by going to my patreon there will
be a link there tonight
uh if not uh before we come back to you
next week gosh I want to say
um
yeah your your patreon conversations are
actually not next week we're we have to
reschedule them uh so um they'll be the
following week
um but we'll be back same time same
place next week for our live stream not
for our q a uh we look forward to seeing
you then
look forward to imagining you then we
won't be seeing you at all
uh we will not be seeing that we will be
inferring their presence we look forward
to inferring you then until then be good
to the ones you love eat good food and
get outside meanwhile everyone
foreign
[Music]